[Music]
welcome to the news and review show i'm
your host definition and it's rather a
documentary comes along that changes
your perception of the world
but from the off the great hack on
netflix opened my eyes to a lot of
things
the two hour long piece which dropped
this week centers around cambridge
analytica
and how their data mining and
monetization of messages
highly influence both the trump
presidential campaign and
outcome of brexit both are highly
controversial aspects of society
and the documentary expertly uses
eyewitness testimony from both
whistleblowers and conspiracy theorists
to paint the picture that life on the
web has us all tangled within it
the piece is pretty revolutionary and
it's often difficult for documentaries
to really capture your imagination for
prolonged periods
however the great hack manages to do
this due to its gripping narrative
throughout it analyzes how as a species
we've sold our souls to social media
and because of this we become
commodities that are able to be targeted
by those with an agenda
who may wish to persuade us to come
around to their way of thinking
there are huge names attached to the
project and throughout i was really
shocked at the reveals and revelations
that the way i'd used the internet had
turned me into a target that was going
to be manipulated by the likes of
facebook and cambridge analytica
this is a really harrowing thing to be
faced with and whilst watching the film
i often felt like i'd been conned in
some way and began
questioning whether my thoughts were
indeed my own it's a really amazing
documentary that massively will make you
question your choices in the past
and if they were really your own similar
to things like supersize me
bowling for columbine and more this
documentary accomplishes its goal of
forcing you to stand back and analyze
whether indulging in these things
is worth the overall cost it's such a
powerful message and when the
documentary
finally brings up mark zuckerberg's
meeting with congress you really get
behind the work and want to see whether
there is any help to the hull that
humanity has dug itself into
from here escalates and feels like a
real tale of the people versus power
it's an excellent chronicle of just how
much
we have to take back our personal data
and ultimately lets us know that going
forward we need to be diligent in
fighting against big corporations that
see us as a means to an end
it perfectly picks its heroes and
villains and really makes you question
the way the world operates in modern
times
overall the great hack is probably the
best documentary of 2019 thus far and
netflix have created a masterpiece that
will likely be looked back on in future
years as a time capsule of what caused
brexit and trump's election
whether they be for better or worse they
even answer the conspiracy theory that
your phone microphone is always
recording
and let us know that no we are creatures
of habit and can be easily fooled
manipulated and persuaded into certain
directions
the great hack makes us realize that in
the end we have to carry more
responsibility ourselves in what we post
and do online
and yeah i'm pretty much off to delete
the internet
right now okay maybe just facebook in
the end i really can't big this
documentary
up enough and that's why it gets a
perfect
10 out of 10. obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts on the great hack and if
you enjoyed it as much as i did
comment below and let me know and if you
like this review then please give it a
thumbs up
and make sure you check out my video
which breaks down my favorite chapter of
the book it by stephen king
that covers the fate of adrian mellon
and it's definitely worth watching if
you want to know more about the upcoming
film
and i'll leave that linked at the end
and hopefully see you over there after
this
if you want to come chat to me about
movies tv shows documentaries or
anything on netflix
then you can follow me on twitter if you
still have it at definition yt
and i'm always happy to talk to people
so make sure you stop by
cheers this is the channel for people
who are mad into movies
so if that's the kind of thing you like
hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this i've been definition
you've been the best and i'll see you
next time take care
peace
[Music]
you